[Music]
you can't fool me with that musical
fake-out movie John Williams did not
score this film and this is just the
first of several times that I'm reminded
how much better the original movies were
welcome to the wonderful world of Harry
Potter now with 100 percent left Harry
Potter also with this new series be the
better call song prequels or will it be
Star Wars it's going to take for more
future cash cows to figure that out
you know maybe these Wizards shouldn't
have given away their position so
clumsily if they were searching for an
evil Dark Lord on a foggy night I mean
seriously it's like they weren't even
prepared for this kind of power as they
scooby-doo their way towards this castle
I'm not one for sensationalism but
shouldn't Gellert Grindelwald Dark
Wizard strikes again in Europe get more
than a regular front page headline seems
like it's important enough to squeeze
out the culture in sports sections that
are still prominently featured along
with the case of the pincushion pygmy
puffs also storytelling through
newspaper headlines look guys I know you
probably had budget restraints since you
only made seven billion seven hundred
twenty-three million four hundred thirty
one thousand five hundred seventy two
dollars with the last eight movies but
maybe there are better ways to hide the
fact that Johnny Depp is starring as
Colin Farrell in this movie why are the
headlines of these newspapers in clear
English and the articles are written in
that language from arrival you know what
the suitcase and everything it
represents we're talking about the magic
world here where you can stuff an entire
world of fantastic beasts into it but
you can't keep a full life secure you
know what the suitcase and everything
represents if you have a muggle worthy
switch on your suitcase why not always
have that switch flipped until you get
into a safe place the haircut the way he
shot from behind like the first shot up
Grindelwald the fact that graves didn't
even bother to change the first two
letters of his last name and his utter
disdain for no Maja's is a dead giveaway
that graves is actually Grindelwald but
we'll spend another two hours pretending
that's not the case
fantastic tremors and where to find them
those images of the baby why don't you
find an easier access point to the
stairway that there are definitely
easier ways to get to the stairs and the
one you've just picked also why did Mary
Lou pick the bank steps to do her
evangelizing was there an anti unicorn
protest already going on outside City
Hall from the perspective of this
creature trying to claw its way out of
the case which contains an entire world
how does it know where the exit of this
case is and if the space in the suitcase
is so crazy huge because of magic why
does the creature so desperately want to
get out of it also the suitcase and
everything represents new is the only
mother courtesy to sniffler even though
it's out in broad daylight and there's a
crowd of people looking right at it
enlisted thanks fella leaves behind and
almost ready to hatch magic lake on the
bench providing an early indication that
he's the worst magical animal Wrangler
in the history of magical animal
Wranglers at a patina know to follow
Newt into the bank did she also see in
the flirt and do nothing because she
definitely doesn't know who Newt is
Hawaii
dammit this Bank has the most oblivious
motherfuckers I've ever seen not only
does no one notice the rodent could
stealing everyone they conveniently
missed two grown men operating without
batting an eyelash
you'll be tries to introduce baby group
without marbles approval how the fuck
did she know they transport here now
look did you know that did they tell me
to care the nomads no magic turn on
wizard oh sorry we call the muggles so
the British call the muggles and the
Americans apparently have never heard of
slang what are you a narc anyway there's
any one reader of Appaloosa popkins in
the world and it'll is Anil later we
learned this in the line why would new
need a cover story at all he's going to
Arizona to release a magical bird is
that illegal you don't know I don't know
movie doesn't know so they enter the
Woolworth Building which secretly houses
an entirely other magic building where
magic people do magic things these
wizards could have cured all the cancer
but instead most of their energy was
devoted to creating a magical vortex of
space what guy there's a lot of
suffering in the world but I want to be
able to hold goldbricks in my wallet can
we make that happen
Olli how are you supposed to tell the
difference between zero low and moderate
threats they're almost the same color
this is a poorly designed alert system
even for an American government
institution major investigation
department I got a section 3a
even if this is a wise old Goblin why
would a elevator operator know the codes
or the different crime levels
terrorizing no matches and when no
Maddy's are afraid they attack this is
what happens when you create a nation of
uncreated fools in your movie you make
them say no match a whole bunch everyone
sounds like their tongues are competing
in an equestrian event to form sentences
look I'm putting the blame squarely on
JK Rowling for making me think vag every
time I hear people say this also much
like the central conflict of every x-men
movie why didn't magic people care what
happens if humans figure out they exist
can't they just kill them all if they
attack or at least be able to survive
the brunt of any kind of attack no
longer an aura the only reason Tina was
allowed to walk in on a high-level
presidential meeting is to bring some
cheap exposition out of the story that
needs very little expedition shot no but
what the
how many messages are lost just because
the words are too lazy to do their own
filing they seriously came to the
decision making sentient origami pets
that may destroy each other from time to
time is the best course of action
movie steals the settle switcheroo trick
from home alone 3 sir grandma damn Jacob
has a picture of his grandma right over
his bed
good luck bringing a gal home without
happening although it probably does help
with the endurance collect early sets
before you get food children miss
bare-bones home for Exploited Children
we interrupt this Harry Potter movie for
something that surely was in Star Wars
The Phantom Menace or John Carter or
avatar apparently with this and Jupiter
ascending Eddie Redmayne really loves
being in movies where unforgettable
destruction occurs and somehow every
single person in the area who witnessed
it can be made to forget also is the
ability to reconstruct physical
buildings something that was taught in
Wizarding school back in the early 20th
century according to this movie any
Wizard can do it but I didn't see those
Harry Potter kids do this even once I
know that you have rather backwards
knows about relations with non-magic
people that you're not meant to befriend
them that you can't marry them which
seems not only said to make sure that
some lame right there but are you
telling me Great Britain had progressive
laws back in the 1920s or did I watch
that imitation game moving all wrong the
director said let's have something
invisible steal and eat an apple it'll
make them look like even more of an
asshole even though they're invisible
absolutely nobody sees this except for
animals crazy disturbances in the subway
this movie is basically skipped over
what is the main plot of this movie and
we're nearly at the end of the first act
our main character some asshole who
carries exotic animals around in a magic
suitcase and that suitcase by the way
nothing about what he's done or what he
carries really seems to solve a problem
presented by the main conflict and in
fact this movie seems to be two movies
and one because of it did you know freak
want to pretend crash free all along
completely unnecessary insult turns into
a huge plot device because hey we got to
flesh out the screenplay that's based on
a textbook magic dressing is virtually
no different from everyday dickhead
muggle dressing illegitimate yeah but I
always have trouble with your kind
Prince that's British also legitimate is
someone who can read minds someone that
was never once introduced in the entire
world of Harry Potter before now
probably because like the time-turner
they were all burning some fires and
seriously new can't just do a simple
akio spill or something to retrieve this
magical bug right now
Wow sit down mr. Scamander welcome
poison you
Newton Tina are both extremely
nonchalant about the urgency of finding
the multiple dangerous beasts that are
running rampant in New York King City
the perks of being an obscure division
showed only the child's immense power he
or she's no older than 10 I saw this
child in cloaks proximity tear mother
craves vision conveniently gives him all
the details about the obscure except the
most important part also let's talk
about visions visions and movies are the
worst thing ever right give just enough
information to be misleading to the
person having the vision this guy was so
incredible with visions Shirley has the
power to figure out that the guy
standing right in front of him is the
person he's looking for my own pot back
to Chacon pocket only kids but at least
they didn't get Hobbit rabies or troll
meningitis nobody's had a dignified
death almost this is like it's a
greatest meal I've ever had in my life
Jacob who was just on death's door a few
minutes ago though seems perfectly fine
here which proves the power of strudels
and boners is even greater than regular
wizardry eel and I will need to be half
a day tomorrow morning to find my
necklace Newt knows there are much more
dangerous creatures that escaped
considering the condition of Jacobs
apartment but is focused on his goddamn
nibbler like a necklace uh-huh it's a
platypus style creature that likes to
steal money Jesus is that so hard given
the other teasing it's ridiculous Tina
would make the knitler discussion
off-limits I thought you might like a
hot drink I also thought you might like
to see this spoon stirring the drinks to
prove how lazy magic folk are so he's
the real reason I came to America to
bring Frank come to the wilds of Arizona
okay I understand Newt had to travel in
New York from England to get to America
why didn't he go immediately to the
train station and start their journey to
Arizona also how does Frank the CGI
eagle Colossus live a great life in
Arizona
what another people see this guy and
want to exploit him or hunt him I know I
know magic everything but you had to
physically walk down into his cage
kennel and the creatures that got out
did so by climbing out the top so Nootka
discount Buckbeak through the opening of
the case in the first place this montage
of all the beasts with new giving the
background on them is awesome
so I'm tempted to remove this hit well
fed I'm reminded that this comprises
only 3% of the movies run time when it
should be almost entirely this so Senate
I will ah sorry no Don Patton yeah had
to defend themselves Eddie nuke begins
his pattern of giving the information
about the dangers of these animals only
after they display the dangerous there
is no way new alone is able to feed and
maintain all these creatures on a
consistent basis fact why isn't using
magic to get done around here earlier
queenie was using spells to do her
Andriy follow the bubble are you kidding
me Newt keeps and obscurus the most
dangerous thing in this universe it is
conceptual they would have it at you in
a heartbeat what's Olivia hope you like
you wake up and oh man we have magic
Gunnar
movie waits 46 minutes to define a term
that's been used about 94 times so far
this is a funny moment but if there's
anything we know about the nibbler it's
that he don't give a about being seen
stealing he should be standing on that
window with his knitler dick out given
to nibbler fingers to anyone on the
street
fenestra we saw this asshole open a
goddamn safe with his magic earlier but
now he's got a break glass to get inside
this store the scene is pretty hilarious
physical comedy and it has no goofy
musical accompaniment in fact it has no
music at all making it even funnier and
for that I will remove the sin I just
gave new for the bullshit glass breakage
which is still both by the way I never
thought I'd say this but movie steal the
scene from angels and demons thank you
god damn it if he can just I mean why
doesn't he do this every mother he could
use this on all the son of a bitch why
would I have to wear something like this
because your skala susceptible to
breakage and their immense force and
yours isn't if the girls heard this from
their apartment that all of midtown
Manhattan showed up too but not one
person shows up at the park to
investigate Eddie Redmayne professional
actor ladies and gentleman also this is
some bull also even if the eruptive
smells the sex juice and here's Newt
doing the mating dance she can still see
right but where does it go
the entrance to the case zoo is newts
little workshop which definitely
wouldn't fit in a rabbit you can't use
its magic to explain all this movie even
when they had that huge magical tent and
Goblet of Fire there were some rules
ladies and gentlemen I give you the
Senator for New York Henry Shaw oh yeah
I remember that cease to worry about the
political family with the paper and the
John voice and the what Evers yeah me
neither
also who makes campaign speeches in the
dead of night we saw Newton Kowalski
going to bed a minute ago and they've
had some adventures in the empty streets
of New York City which suggests even
more passage of time but apparently you
can get a whole bunch of rich white
people out at 2:00 in the morning to
watch campaign speeches Madam President
I'm sorry to interrupt
is critical Tina once again Walters
right look I know it has to be a tightly
secured presidential meeting aren't
these cool Wizards I guess this is a
dead politician guy but apparently the
Wizarding community doesn't have any
better visual aids than the assholes and
the Hunger Games
wait why the hell did they lock Tina she
turned them in was it so that we can
have an obviously expositional
conversation while incarcerated moment
if so Bravo young losses in which is
sometimes tried to suppress that magic
that developed what was called and
obscures sons they want controllable
dark force to fuss thousand attacks so
this is how obscure eels are created the
told not to touch their lawns or though
grow hair on their phones or go blind
also this means that obscurus is an
obvious metaphor for teen angst that
gets so bad it causes irreparable harm
if so they should have just named it an
emo band come to think of it obscurus
would be a terrific name for anymore man
what makes Albus Dumbledore so fond of
him mainly he just likes being
referenced and newt was always kind
enough to do that everywhere you went so
setting a pack of dangerous creatures
loose here was just another accident
that right I did everything to expose
little guy provoke war between the
magical in our magical world I don't
know one of Grendel was fanatics the
original title of this movie was x-men
and where to find them seriously Grendel
Wald is Magneto and this is essentially
x2 all over again and there's the guilty
of a treasonous betrayal if your fellow
is is and sentenced to death
I know graves is Grindelwald and
circumventing the system but shouldn't
one or two of the witches behind them
suggest there be some sort of wizard
court to approve this do it immediately
and by immediately I mean drag it out
for several minutes while giving them
ample opportunity to escape you know
while we're at it
Snoopy has a lot of Minority Report in
it too Colin Farrell Samantha Morton
visions of the future jails that are
some kind of purgatory it's not that
much of a stretch in cinemasins world
whatever this punishment is noop has to
wait for kini to go through her entire
life story before he himself has to go
through it incredibly complicated
magically secure door is no match for a
swift kick from a port we know magic
creeping death wave conveniently leaves
a gigantic opening from right where Tina
needs to escape quick bullshit
manufactured tension for the escape
scene is manufactured and bold holy Sh
what kind of relationship is this this
is just a kid right the child is dying
crazy
time is running out it continues to chap
my ass that Grindelwald knows so much
about the obscure
and is this close to the actual host but
has no concludes the flash the
grandfather kept pictures
somebody is raising pigeons for some
goddamn reason on a department rooftop
cliche we need to catch all your
preachers anyone still missing
I know there are two and for a
supposedly super detailed creature
caretaker
that's a weird detail to miss huh I
wonder why Queenie didn't do this
earlier in the movie when Tina asked her
to get dressed and she decided to go
with he looks the same as muggle
dressing with a little magic technique
[Music]
only Dan Fogler I far the best thing
about this movie and this moment kills
me so once and off her ass is half of
the people in here but apparently
they're super cool with it because no
one is from Edina aa recognizable CGI
goblin Ron Perlman something this was
wreaking havoc around 50 G's why did
they even have to pay this guy anything
for information that wouldn't news of an
invisible something or other be pretty
big news maybe they should have asked
around town and gotten some leads before
trying the gangster goblin even though
the obscurus is out and prom at this
point we've still got time to show
another be snapping because even after
an hour and a half movie still can't
decide what's primary storyline is also
gnarl axes check out Maisie sandy king
invisible thing is not only there but
openly stealing in front of the window
it's almost like it wasn't a conflict at
all dinner guys ghosts in the shells his
invisibility when he's alone even though
it'd be much easier to just remain
invisible so you can foresee the most
likely immediate future creature as
Nicolas Cage's skills from next and
movie thinks that impresses me Cochran
he's chronic desi
a crisis in available space we've seen
these things a couple times in this
movie and know this hasn't happened
until now we need an insect and it's tea
time this will be just turned into Alice
in Wonderland Dennis does nobody
remember the akio spell when they're
trying to reach for something I be using
that all the time well that's pretty
much it right
creatures escape crazy ensues everything
gets back to normal Newt heads to
Arizona what we've still got that
obscure storyline to tie up and a Johnny
Depp cameo by the way this suitcase
fishy eyes knowing leaving this change
I've heard of that family
this franchise basically doing what the
motherfucking avec did where the whole
thing is leading up to Voldemort because
audiences can't accept the prequel
series without seeing the origin story
of some sort of dark Sauron you know
what I think it is but if not here's
it's in anyway
anyway there's a dumb time today have we
seen the anyway it was a long time ago
cliche before if we did I bet it was a
long time ago Tim's like a meal close if
you could read minds the absolute most
annoying thing you could do is finish
someone's goddamn sentences
morning it's only the best physical in
the world please define the best
visiting school in the world he's a
hopeful look at this American school has
anybody who teaches anything and doesn't
have a schoolmaster who ignores his
students it's already better than
Hogwarts there's squid creams your
mother's dead that's your reward it sure
Grindelwald is a dickhead i unleashed
his tirade on Creedence before his
sister's found he could still need his
help right Creedence was super pissed at
graves but flew right past him to go
wreak havoc instead of killing it
presumably because he knew he's actually
Johnny Depp as I see this obscurus doing
all this damage in plain sight of the
mill majus I'm thinking about the
Oblivion spell and the construction work
nuke did earlier and I realized there
are no stakes to this final
confrontation small possible many you
know newt is supposed to be a creature
expert all of a sudden he knows every
goddamn thing about obscure eels because
the plot needs a convenient expert
witness come back no cost of my
creatures mind is a heavy responsibility
to lay on someone you just met yesterday
doesn't have fellow beast masters who
are eminently more qualified yeah
they're typically dangerous to humanity
but this obscurus is really more into
property damage oh great another wand
off just like Deathly Hallows part-2
older if this will also end with an
all-powerful wizard trying to physically
kick someone to death
even though they have no idea where
credence is heading the cops hilariously
picked this random street to enforce an
armed roadblock they killed my son I
want justice Libby continues to try to
make the Jon Voight storyline a thing
thankfully you know just because a
person is obliviated how would that
affect photographs shouldn't right
so these Mikasa buttholes are exposed as
hell the guy who will be revealed to be
Grindelwald is definitely trying to kill
new here so why not Hakuna Matata
I mean Avada Kedavra his asked do you
realize what you've done um probably not
much if I learned anything from Harry
Potter movies the only way your
character is truly dead is if you're
Robert Pattinson something evil X not
gonna for like the third time in this
movie he is 1 June Law away from being
the Imaginarium of Doctor Parnassus 2
fantastic Boogaloo also let's talk about
Grindelwald plant apparently despite
constant winning he needed to infiltrate
magic Congress USA and become a powerful
leader inside it all to have the
resources to find this obscure but why I
didn't need ya credence was powerful all
the Grindelwald has been killing people
left and right without any help this is
so needlessly complicated and obviously
a setup for a surprise that it makes the
last hour so completely ridiculous
if you had a vision of this powerful
child why not just go to Samantha
Morton's house just kidnap all the kids
do this reveal EO spell and find the
obscure oh that way or a million other
ways that don't involve being part of a
magic Congress the new tale the unruly
beast in the suitcase not to escape this
time and they kept their word while this
discount Phoenix flew out of it
[Music]
inst oblivion so this is rain that's
going to make everyone forget about the
magic they just saw all right I don't
work for everyone who's outside right
now but this movie will have you believe
that these assholes in their apartment
are forgetting to and that's in both
this movie actually thinks we'll let's
lie also the wizards and witches go
about fixing everything once again
proving this movie is Jupiter ascending
under a different title how do they know
where all the damages there are
certainly buildings they will miss in
the scenario because it's impossible to
know the entire extent also also I do
wonder about some of these people on the
inside getting affected by the rain like
are we supposed to believe everyone saw
something they shouldn't last night by
the way nobody from the magic government
decided to make sure they went through
with obliviated this guy they could have
easily just not done it and or him to
secrecy of course what does it matter if
one guy claims that magical people exist
isn't that guy considered crazy
Jesus is there a more useless feature of
an all-powerful wand and to make it into
a king umbrella please take these
alchemy egg shells as collateral filled
bakery thanks take this kind of
collateral and doesn't just break the
magic non-magical code come the king
he'll mother in bitch ash on we waited
until now to wrap some twine around this
motherfucker I'm out of here
how the Caltrain fantastic beasts and
where I find roll credits seriously
roll the goddamn credits alright this
movie saying that spike being made to
forget everything he's seen Kowalski
still has imprints of those memories
somehow hmm I don't think I like that
I guess Queenie put a spell on all the
people who were in line just 30 seconds
ago she shooed away his customers
the magic a to me
[Music]
come Wendy let us try to jump the hilly
brush what drew you to our meeting today
where I find the witch why we blow it up
get some of these brand brand Lord is my
shepherd and so forth and so on the past
what your la la who is what we call an
orgy of evidence know many orgies I had
as a homicide cop courney Eleni nun the
bank must be protected mr. Kowalski
well you get nothing you lose
good day sir what are you some kind of
investigator what we some kind of
Suicide Squad piece
I hope to move
you
[Music]
let's be honest this was hitting world
here is never exactly been known for
healthy eating you ever stomped but if
you're a fantastic beast wrangling
weirdo with a magical zoo in your
satchel I'm thinking you got room for
some freaking snacks dude make your box
is perfect for snacking for a ton of
reasons wanna get huh come on let's get
nut they shipped to your door they come
in handy portable bags and best of all
they're healthy right now if you go to
naturebox.com/tyler the sins and use the
code sins you can get your first three
snacks for free ha ha ha Jarrod are you
ok so many motion free 3 entire snacks
for free you can get my favorite the
cheddar sourdough pretzels mmm something
or try the new strawberry lemon-aid mini
star fruit juice they are constantly
adding new snacks taking suggestions and
all around improving their already
fantastic service and product take it
from me I'm not an expert I'm just a kid
but I'm still right make your box rules
go to naturebox.com/tyler the Sims today
and used to code Sims to get your first
three snacks free go don't out cool